c'est gelé dit du cousu main
c'est la volonté de faire de la
collectivité d'alsace une collectivité
en avance par rapport à ce que pourra
être le schéma institutionnel demain
c'est à dire de partir de la base des
compétences départementales des deux
départements alsaciens pour créer une
connectivité dotés de compétences
particulières et supplémentaires le 29
octobre dernier edouard philippe a
annoncé la signature d'un accord entre
le gouvernement et les présidents des
conseils départementaux du bas rhin et
du haut rhin
l'accord ainsi signé vise à la création
en 2021 d'un super départements d'alsace
au sein de la région grand est
une signature qui annonce le retour de
l'alsace sur les cartes de france et met
un terme à des mois de négociations pour
faire reconnaître le désir d'alsace de
populations qui n'avaient pas digéré de
voir leur région se fondre dans le grand
est déjà en septembre 2016 soit quelques
mois à peine après le début la grande
région
les deux exécutifs départementaux
annoncé publiquement leur désir de voir
l'alsace redevenir une réalité
institutionnelle
ma priorité c'est que nos étudiants
colis
les prochaines semaines et avant les
présidentielles toutes les options qui
peuvent sauver l'amour sans amour pour
que l'alsace réalité humaine citoyenne
économie redevienne un an plus tard
après avoir mené un important lobbying
alsacien auprès du président
nouvellement élu
les lignes bougent au sommet de l'état
au mois de novembre 2017
lors d'une rencontre avec le président
de la république le président de la
république nous a dit on peut imaginer
une identité particulière pour l'alsace
mais à une condition c'est qu'elle reste
dans le grand est
nous sommes des élus républicains nous
sommes alsacien nous avons décidé avec
frédéric biri de tenter cette aventure
avec le gouvernement à savoir de
travailler ensemble sur un projet de
collectivité à l'instinct les élus et
laborde donc un projet de collectivité
alsacienne basé sur l'échelon
départemental renforcé de nouvelles
compétences aidé par la région et l'état
une déclaration commune cap vers
l'alsace est signée en février par 130
élus et personnalités alsaciennes au
printemps une consultation citoyenne
rassemble quelque 13000 participation
qui viennent appuyer le projet
parallèlement le gouvernement confie au
préfet marx la réalisation d'un rapport
sur l'avenir institutionnel de l'alsace
la machine est lancée de l'état nous
souhaitons pouvoir récupérer les routes
nationales le transfrontalier et
l'apprentissage
des langues et notamment l'allemand pour
nous c'est un enjeu majeur il ya 3 % de
chômage en allemagne donc la possibilité
de placer les jeunes de placer des
chômeurs de longue durée en allemagne
c'est quelque chose qu'on construit mais
un des handicaps que nous vivons au
quotidien c'est la connaissance de la
langue donc nous la dynamique économique
de notre territoire la dynamique de
l'emploi dépend des directement d'un
travail partenarial qu'on peut
construire avec le territoire du bas
durant mère et deux territoires de bâle
où le territoire allemand et suisse et
donc ses compétences là nous les
appelons de nos voeux de pouvoir les
récupérer en août 2010 8 le rapport
remis au premier ministre par le préfet
marx reconnaît le dr risa et évoque les
différentes pistes institutionnels pour
le concrétiser
à sa suite le premier ministre confie à
jacqueline gourault secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur la
mission de mener les négociations
s'engage alors un round de discussions
jusqu'à la signature de l'accord du 29
octobre le travail que nous avons pu
construire avec la mine et céline gros
mais aussi le ministre blanc caire ont
contribué à améliorer la copie c'est
vrai que je dois vous avouer que je dis
je n'aurais pas signé
aujourd'hui nous signons c'est qu'un
début il ya encore des marges de progrès
à voir là il va falloir maintenant
travailler sur les outils juridiques à
mettre en place et il va falloir que les
deux départements délibère pour créer le
support juridique qui va permettre la
création de cette collectivité alsace
ainsi l'accord stipule que la
collectivité européenne d'alsace sera
issu de la fusion des deux départements
dont elle récupérera les compétences
elle disposera par ailleurs de
compétences supplémentaires en matière
de coopération transfrontalière 2
bilinguisme de tourisme et de transport
le 26 novembre était posé le premier
jalon de la future collectivité à
sélestat les élus des deux assemblées se
réunissent et pour adopter une
résolution ainsi qu'une feuille de route
dans le but de poursuivre le processus
législatif écouter l'ensemble des
conseillers départementaux sur quels
étaient leurs visions les comment il
s'inscrivait dans la démarche et il ya
il ya une détermination collective forte
qui s'est exprimé une volonté partagée
de d'aboutir et un soutien fort que nous
nous pouvons bénéficier de nos collègues
nous les deux présidents et ça c'est
effectivement important parce que ça
nous aide dans la construction quotidien
du projet si l'assemblée ainsi constitué
n'a pas de valeur légale les résolutions
devant être prises séparément dans les
deux assemblées départementales avant
qu'elles soient réunies en 2021
les conseillers ont tout de même voté à
l'unanimité le soutien à la démarche des
deux présidences l'opposition quand elle
n'a pas souhaité prendre part au vote
c'est vraiment une journée historique
pour pour l'alsace puisque c'est la
validation à l'unanimité par nos
collègues des accords de matignon que
frédéric berry et moi avons signé le 29
octobre dernier avec le premier ministre
si cette réunion des assemblées
départementales a une forte valeur en
terme de symbole il reste encore
beaucoup de chemin à parcourir et 2021
par la suite et et de plusieurs ordres
il ya la suite juridique 1 ou doute dû
prendre une délibération les mêmes
délibération dans les deux collectivités
départementale du haut-rhin et du
bas-rhin donc ça c'est un premier
élément
nous allons travailler que le
gouvernement sur le contenu du texte de
loi parce que ça ça va être aussi un
élément fondateur fort et en parallèle
nous rebat les lions les futures
politiques publiques pour voir comment
on peut préfigurer déjà leur mise en
oeuvre
et puis nous regardons comment notre âme
nous pourrons encore mieux améliorer les
politiques publiques actuelles
que nous portons dans chaque
collectivité départementale
[Musique]